[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
we have an exclusive first look at a
corona virus testing program
designed to help americans feel more
comfortable about air travel
united airlines is rolling out this
rapid testing in san francisco for
flights to hawaii
if it works there united hopes to offer
testing options
at its major hubs across the country
that potentially
could allow americans to travel
internationally again
chris van cleave is at dulles
international airport outside washington
chris how's this going to work
well good morning the day could be
coming where every one of these planes
as they taxi out
is full of passengers who have just been
tested for covet
we're not there yet this program is
starting small
but if it can work to hawaii united
hopes it could be used to work to get
americans flying all over the world once
again
i'm getting tested united employee
eduardo marquez is getting the rapid
covet test passengers at san francisco
airport will soon be taken just hours
before departing for hawaii
it was simple fast
not invasive at all united is the first
u.s airline to roll out a cova testing
program for passengers
starting october 15th bay area flyers
bound for hawaii will be given the
option to order an at-home testing kit
or reserve a time for a rapid test at
the airport
and we really see this as a great
opportunity to provide
access to testing for our customers to
get them back in the air
and traveling as safely as possible
hawaii has been largely closed to
tourists since march
but next month with proof of a negative
coveted test result within 72 hours
prior to arrival
the state will waive its two-week
quarantine hawaii officials will verify
those results as flights come in
richard pagano flew to maui wednesday if
he got me out of quarantine for two
weeks
it's a lot of extra time back to me can
also make sure that i'm not
getting my friends sick or anyone who is
like in the risk zone sick
the rapid testing at sfo is already
available to airport and airline
employees it takes about
20 minutes from arrival to result and
initially will cost 250 dollars
the at-home kit will be 80 bucks plus
shipping and go to this san francisco
lab for processing
flyers will have results within 48 hours
united hopes to eventually
expand testing options to its hubs
across the country in cities like new
york chicago and los angeles
being able to identify a positive case
and
pull them out of a public health
situation and put them in isolation and
then be able to kind of winnow that
group of potential infectious
individuals
is really what's going to have an impact
new york's jfk and newark airports are
working with a private company
express check to offer passengers flying
any airline a rapid copa test before
departure
a recent atmosphere research survey
found three-fourths of flyers support
pre-flight coveted testing united sees
this effort as a major step towards
reconnecting the u.s with international
travel
airlines are pushing for quote air
bridges between major cities like new
york and london
that would require pre-flight coveted
tests for all on board
there does appear to be lawmakers
support for those so-called air bridges
as well linking major u.s cities to
international cities
lufthansa the german carrier says it too
will start rapid testing passengers next
month
that airline has also set up two testing
sites at german airports for arriving
passengers
american airlines tells cbs news it too
is considering
rapid testing for passengers gail okay
so chris i just want to make sure i get
i got this straight
so you get the test before you get on
the flight and you get the results
before you get on the flight correct
correct the idea is that you would have
that negative test result before you
boarded the plane
and flew to hawaii okay because i heard
something different all right and are
they planning to do it in other places
like
new york to california or new york to
chicago
or or or or new york city
places gail months ago places that
anthony loves to go to
are they planning other markets first of
all who doesn't want to go to hawaii
yeah right
who doesn't want to go to hawaii right
yes think of this as a
crawl walk run approach they want to
start with a small sample make
sure that the the process works that the
testing is well received and that
they've got the capacity to expand it
and then grow from there all right chris
van cleef thank you very much
hawaii they could say is a good start
number one it was just name the most
uh happiest day i'm gonna talk about
that later oh you are or to come on
hawaii okay so i'll stop talking about
that and
that it's the number one vacation uh
destination and
bucket list please i've had that rapid
test you have got to result in
literally 20 it's minutes as deep
as the other one it sounds like a game
changer give it to everybody immediately
open schools open offices
very expensive but but if you need
results in a hurry i will also say i
don't think we've ever seen chris
vancleave on the tarmac
usually there's more traffic with planes
i think it's a marker of where we are
right now as a country well i'm getting
one today akovites and i still
don't get used to that thing up your
nose oh the back of the brain yeah it is
not cute
i'm not a good patient